EGCG and sulfurophane are known phytochemicals that in part block metabolic pathways, not
sure I am saying this correctly for cancer stem cells.
Often I hear that whole foods that contain these nutrients are said to be best, but I find
I rely on supplements far more, is that okay?
So EGCG, sulfurophane, and you could add curcumin, turmeric to that, you could add, you could
really add most of the flavonoids to that, are good things that block cancer stem cells,
also you could add pectosol C to that, and can you get them in foods?
I would say not usually, so you could get turmeric, you could grind up your own turmeric
and make turmeric, you know, juice turmeric, that would be really good, you're never going
to get enough sulfurophane in foods, I guarantee you that, you're never going to get enough
EGCG in foods, I remember looking at the data a few years ago, you'd have to drink
on a pure organic green tea, you'd have to drink like 30 glasses of green tea in order
to get enough EGCG in one capsule of a typical EGCG, I think we were compared it to Timoigo
at that time.
The other day I'll say about EGCG and sulfurophane, so EGCG you have to make sure that you get
a really good company, that's why I really like US enzyme, because I went to their facility
and they are like crazy anal about the purity of their EGCG, I know some other companies
are really good with that too, but there's so much garbage, EGCG is the most toxic imported
product, and there is not EGCG, on the market in the United States it doesn't come from
China, which is fine, it doesn't mean it's bad, it's coming from China, but it means
that it can be, so there's a lot of corrupt sellers of products that sell to even good
sustainable companies, that if they're not tested with their own labs, their product
and they're not upright in that, then it's not a good product, so there's several companies,
US enzyme, a premier research, designs for health is good with their testing, there's
some images good for their testing, but and then sulfurophane is another thing, sulfurophane
has to be the really right type, that's why we like the US enzyme, sulfurophane, also
it's the same, it's really a good form of sulfurophane, sulfurophane, I have been using
US enzymes, I like that too, because what you said and my sister says the same thing, as far
as sulfurophane, you can sprout broccoli sprouts, is that any value?
I think it is value, I just don't think you'll get enough with how much you can eat.
That's the issue with that, I think turmeric, I think you could for sure get enough because
that's just ground turmeric, what's on the market, so I think that you could get enough, just
fine with making your own, juicy your own turmeric, it's just, this is not very fun to do
that on a regular basis, that's terrible, yes, it's not really yummy.